Can I just answer one point about doing
more for the poor?
Of course we should do more for the
book,
but why do we assume that it's either
you deal with climate change or you do
something for the poor?
First of all,
climate change,
it's actually they had most of its
effects in the developing countries and
you can increase double or triple the
amount of aid.
It will still,
because of climate change produced
malnutrition,
increasing hunger,
it will certainly,
uh,
data produced more flooding.
Uh,
it'll produce,
uh,
the damage to crops.
Um,
it'll produce unclean water.
It'll increase dysentery.
I mean,
it's not a one or the other.
If you deal with climate change,
we're doing a lot for the poor.